Guten Morgen, Linus.
Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich bin sehr froh, dass dann Präsidenten Maschine heute nicht aufgehalten wurde.
Präsident,
Ja, so als äh ähm Vertreter südamerikanischer Staaten hat man derzeit auf jeden Fall eine aufregende.
Aufregende Ereignisse um sich herum. Das äh erstaunlich. Die Welt ist bewegt. Alle drehen durch und das äh gehören mehreren Stellen.
Wir drehen kräftig mit.
Genau, wir drehen mit. Wir drehen mit hier Lokbuchnetzpolitik. Siebzigste Ausgabe. Siebzig. Schon ganz gut, ne? Ja. Ja, hätten wir auch nicht so gut gedacht, ne?
Hätte gedacht, das Themenfeld erledigt sich irgendwann oder.
Nö, weiß nicht, aber ich meine siebzig Sendungen ist schon äh hat schon so eine gewisse äh äh Starminar. Also da ist man schon.
Ist kein neuer Podcast mehr. Ich würde aber.
Bei dieser neuen Episode noch ganz kurz ähm so äh es gab viele Kommentare zur letzten Sendung oder viele, aber es gab einige,
ja und ähm es wird ja so ein bisschen ähm,
angemerkt, dass wir irgendwie den Edward Snowden nicht äh ausreichend äh loben äh und dass wir vielleicht der ganzen,
ein bisschen zu äh sarkastisch und zynisch begegnen, was sie diesen Überwachungsskandal angeht. Deswegen möchte ich nur ähm einmal kurz sagen, also Tim hat ja gerade schon gesagt, siebzig Folgen,
Wenn man siebzig Folgen sich irgendwie ausschließlich mit schlechten Nachrichten auseinandersetzt, ja? Also wir können ja hier nichts machen als es gibt grundsätzlich nur Schlechtes zu berichten.
Nur Schlechtes zu berichten. Genau, ihr wisst, die Überbringer schlechter Nachrichten haben generell einen schlechten Stand.
Und ähm allein um äh da den den äh Mut äh oder die die Freude äh aufrecht zu erhalten, müssen wir uns da auch ein bisschen äh Sarkasmus jeweils gönnen.
Ja und ich meine, das ist jetzt auch nicht, weiß ich nicht, nicht unbedingt jetzt unsere Aufgabe äh jetzt hier jedem Aktivisten das entsprechende Hedge Programm zukommen zu lassen. Wenn die Leute tun, was sie tun,
Das ist ja äh soweit auch in Ordnung,
Sicherlich äh gibt's da auch viel Lobenswertes, aber wir sind ja jetzt hier nicht der äh Jubel-Podcast, der irgendwie äh äh Aktivistenpokale verteilt, sondern wir versuchen halt einfach ein bisschen zusammenzufassen, was Sache ist,
Da muss man dann manchmal auch ein bisschen neutral drauf schauen. Das gelingt uns natürlich genauso wenig, ja, da gibt es durchaus äh auch Episoden, wo es dann auch mal,
mit uns etwas durchgeht, so ist das halt, ne? Wir sind auch nicht unfehlbar und vor allem sind wir einfach mal so wie wir sind.
Auf jeden Fall glaube ich sind wir uns brauchen braucht die Hörerschaft sich nicht zu fürchten
dass wir diese Überwachung gutheißen. Wir sind uns auch darüber im Klaren, dass wir hier wahrscheinlich mit dem größten Überwachungsskandal des äh Jahrhunderts zu tun haben. Wobei ich ja diesen Begriff Überwachungsskandal, das heißt, also Skandal ist ja immer so was Abgeschlossenes, ja? Wenn in dem Moment, wo du von dem Skandal,
sprichst und das hast du auch heute schon in den Medien, der äh der Skandal über den in der Vergangenheit,
Vergangenheitsform gesprochen wird. Das ist immer sowas wie äh äh so eine Sache, ne. Also der Skandal wird jetzt äh geklärt, da muss jetzt irgendwann jemand seinen Hut nehmen und dann war das mal ein Skandal. Genauso wie der ähm,
Echolonskandal und so weiter, ja? Also.
Das war ja, das ist ja jetzt auch alles vorbei und jetzt ist ja auch wieder gut.
Genau, das war das ist jetzt, das war ja dann damals der Skandal und ähm dann kam die Kathasis durch äh dadurch, dass das so lange in in der Zeitung stand, bis es wirklich keiner mehr lesen wollte und dann war wieder alles in Ordnung. Ähm,
Gestern Abend war äh Jacob Applebaum äh zu Gast bei im im äh netzpolitischen Amt des äh der digitalen Gesellschaft in der in Berlin.
Das war gut gefüllt.
Das war gut gefüllt. Also.
Gut gefühlt, dass ich dann auch keinen Platz mehr so richtig gefunden habe. Sauerstoff war dann auch nicht mehr im Angebot.
Wenn der es äh wobei die die Abende ja sowieso immer sehr gut besucht sind, aber.
Aber das hat auf jeden Fall alle Rekorde gebrochen ganz.
Einiges raus gesprengt da. Ähm der hat gesagt, es gibt es gibt drei äh Reaktion oder es gibt so drei Reaktionen, die eigentlich,
Die naheliegend sind auf so einen Skandal, die aber nicht,
akzeptabel sind und ähm äh oder die, die beim zweiten Gedanken natürlich nicht äh nicht,
Nicht so gut sind. Wenn er sagte, das erste ist äh zu sagen, ja du bist doch jetzt nicht ernsthaft überrascht. Ja? Ähm.
Bin trotzdem auf dem Punkt, dass ich sage, ich bin über diesen, über diese Abhörausmaße nicht ernsthaft überrascht. Gleichzeitig heißt das aber nicht,
deshalb rechtfertige oder akzeptabel finde. Ja, es ist nur eine,
Sache, dass ich halt eben wie ja viele vielleicht wissen in diesem äh IT-Security-Umfeld eben auch tätig bin und mir da über Computer sehr sehr viele Gedanken mache und deshalb nicht wirklich überrascht bin. Das heißt aber nicht,
dass ich diese Überwachung ähm akzeptabel finde,
Das nur mal so zu zu meiner Gesinnungsfrage. Ähm das das Zweite, das zweite Ding ist, dass Menschen sagen, okay, jetzt ist das Kind eh schon im Brunnen, jetzt können wir eh nichts mehr machen, die Infrastruktur ist da,
Ja, das ist natürlich auch so ein äh.
Punkt dessen ich eventuell in der letzten Folge auch verdächtig geworden bin. Natürlich muss man dagegen kämpfen, aber ähm,
Ich denke, es ist halt, also man muss gleichzeitig auch sich darüber im Klaren sein, dass der Kampf wie immer
an äh mehreren äh Freunden geführt wird, dass ich also einerseits zusehen muss, dass ich
irgendwie legistrativ die Dinge in die Reihe kriege, dass dass solche Sachen wirklich dann verboten werden und nicht passieren und wir nicht Geheimdienste haben, die über jegliche demokratische Entscheidungen wieder drüber stehen, sodass wir irgendwie für Polizei und so eventuell
die Überwachungsbefugnisse einschränken mit demokratischen Mitteln gleichzeitig aber wir Gesetze haben
die Zusammenarbeit, die hier in Deutschland, ja, ne, wo die Zusammenarbeit zwischen Geheimdiensten und Polizei verschärft äh ähm,
verstärkt werden soll, ja?
Und gleichzeitig die Geheimdienste aufgrund des Prinzips sowieso irgendwie über den Gesetzen stehen, ja dann können wir uns diesen ganzen demokratischen Kram ohnehin sparen. Ähm,
und natürlich das letzte Argument, ich glaube, dessen sind wir überhaupt nicht verdächtig, äh dass das alles nur zu unserem Besten geschehe, äh dass äh ist, glaube ich, also ich meine, das ist ja auch so ein so ein so ein, dass er wirklich, dass das Bullshit-Argument schlechthin, ne, also.
Das hätten wir gesagt.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das sind dann die drei äh die drei ähm,
häufigsten Reaktionen äh zusammengefasst von von Jake. Ja? Und dass da, dass man so dass das, was man am häufigsten hört, ne. Du bist doch nicht überrascht. Jetzt ist es eh zu spät und ähm das küssiert doch nur zu unserem Besten, ja? Alle diese drei Argumente sind natürlich ähm,
Sind natürlich Quatsch. Ich denke aber den Punkt, den wir so in unserer letzten Folge einfach ein bisschen betonen wollten, war
Am Ende sind alle nur wütend, dass es die anderen machen. Ja, also Deutschland macht's auch, das ist jetzt irgendwie äh ist jetzt sauer, dass es äh dass es die anderen machen,
Und ähm das möchte ich halt äh in dieser ganzen Sache äh auch nochmal betont haben, damit eben diese ganze Frage des antiamerikanismus oder sogar keine Rolle spielt. Ähm und ich habe in der letzten Folge eben,
denke ich auch ausreichend betont, dass es eben auch nun mal in der äh Ratio eines jeden Staates liegt, äh so zu agieren. Und ähm,
Das ist, dass es da keinen gibt, der äh der das nicht macht. Machst du einen Staat, musst äh Leute überwachen.
Tja, die Frage ist nur, wie und wo und in welchem Ausmaße? Und irgendwie habe ich jetzt so das Gefühl,
Das Ding ist irgendwie noch lange nicht äh zu Ende gespielt. Also man.
Klang, glaube ich, auch gestern Abend schon an, dass noch so das ein oder andere im Busch sei.
Woher solche Informationen jetzt auch immer kommen mögen,
das Ausmaß ist ja jetzt schon beträchtlich, äh vor allem auch der Spiegel hat jetzt grad heute nochmal eine recht gute Zusammenfassung im Übrigen, so der Geschehnisse äh bisher gepostet, wo man sozusagen mal wirklich mal nochmal aufgezählt bekommen hat, was,
Ist denn jetzt eigentlich alles da, ne? Also.
Erstmal die Aktivitäten der NSA, was wir hier auch alles angesprochen haben, so über die Wochen äh also,
halt direkt bei den Telekom Providern und die äh Bewegungsprofile dann eben Prisom und die entsprechenden Netzdienste, Facebook et cetera, der Direkte Zugriff, der ja auch,
wie sich mittlerweile gezeigt hat. Sind wir jetzt eigentlich schon irgendwie im ersten Thema? Also.
Wir wir müssen wir müssen noch weiter, wir müssen.
Ne, also ich will auch gar nicht so sehr ins Detail gehen, also äh die Dimension ist einfach äh äh enorm und ich habe das Gefühl, es wird sich noch weiter verstärken.
Auf jeden Fall noch Sachen. Das haben wir jetzt äh wurde jetzt schon mehreren Leuten schon öffentlich auch angekündigt. Die,
Zumindest in Gesprächen mit mir das dann noch nicht so äh öffentlich gesagt hatten. Also da werden noch ein paar Sachen kommen von äh in im Bereich der Überwachung. Das Thema also der Drops ist noch nicht gelutscht, wobei man ja jedes Mal denkt, so jetzt kann's ja echt nicht mehr schlimmer werden.
Aber da da kommen noch ein paar Sachen, ja? Ähm.
Ja. Fangen wir mal an. Immer noch nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, Moment, Moment, Moment, immer noch nicht, nee. Ähm.
Der längste Prolog ever.
Kurz noch zu empfehlen, ich hatte die Sendung ja schon angekündigt, letzte Mal, ich persönlich war war, fand sie nur so mittel gut, das Feedback irgendwie über Twitter war, aber sehr, sehr positiv, deswegen empfehle ich nochmal das äh Chaos-Radio,
äh wo äh wo ich zu Gast war, zusammen mit äh.
Mhm.
Margun und äh Erdgeist und Andi Müller Magun ist einfach mal derjenige, den man fragen möchte, äh wenn's um solche Sachen geht. Der hat da ähm eine,
sehr,
sehr großen Ehrgeiz sich mit diesen Themen auseinanderzusetzen und da auch eine ja eine eine gesunde, vielleicht auch streckenweise gar nicht mehr ganz so äh übliche Besessenheit mit diesem Thema und ist da einfach.
Also er hat nicht nur den Ehrgeiz, er tut es vor allem auch schon seit äh zwanzig, fünfundzwanzig Jahren und äh tut es eben auch mit einer.
Leidenschaft, Leidenschaft ist, glaube ich, der der richtige Begriff.
Leidenschaft, das ist schön formuliert, ja.
Und das ist also derjenige, den man äh fragen möchte in allen äh Bereichen der dreiundzwanzig und der hat da sehr äh sehr interessante Hintergründe in dieser äh in dieser Chaos-Radiosendung beleuchtet. Die
leider dann oft natürlich wieder viel zu kurz ist, aber ich empfehle das mal und ähm einen kleinen Teil von den Sachen, die Andi erzählt hat.
Ich fand ja die Geschichte mit den äh automatischen Brieföffnungssystemen im deutsch-deutschen Grenzverkehr fand ich ja großartig.
Ja, also er hat ja, das ist schon.
Paar schöne Perlen drin.
Also auf jeden Fall mal zu empfehlen äh in in solchen Themenfeldern sich äh mal was man an die Müller erzählen zu lassen, der ja übrigens auch die Seite Bugd äh Planet,
Info glaube ich unterhält, wo so diese ganzen, wir hatten die hier auch schon öfters erwähnt.
Wo diese ganzen Überwachungstechnologien und Firmen auch dann einfach mal dokumentiert werden,
Jetzt kommen wir noch zu den Errater zur letzten Sendung.
Ja, ich hatte nämlich, ich hatte nämlich geschätzt, äh, Gruppe überschlagen, dass es acht Cent am Tag kostet, äh, sich pro Bundesbürger sich von der Vorratsdatenspeicherung freizukaufen,
in Form von Strafzahlungen an die EU,
Das war äh da habe ich mich um mehrere Faktoren vertan. Denn es eigentlich ist nur ein Faktor, aber es ist ein sehr großer.
Von der ja mathematisch korrekt.
Ähm.
Es kostet zwölf Cent und zwar nicht am Tag, sondern pro Monat. Also mein Angebot steht, ich zahle,
Eins zwanzig, mach mal eins fünfzig. Und äh nehmen Zahl für zehn von euch mit, ne.
Im Monat kann ich machen, kann ich mir leisten.
Naja, trotz alledem, das ist eine Menge Geld.
Die da gezahlt werden muss, das ist nicht schön, ja? Ich meine, da kann man sich jetzt drüber erheben, dass das ja nur Geld ist, äh so dreihunderttausend Euro pro Tag. Das ist definitiv eine Hausnummer. Damit kann man äh könnte man da so,
den Widerstand gegen äh Nazis und äh anderes Unwesen in Deutschland ganz erheblich nach vorne bringen. Wenn man das Geld vielleicht eher in solche Sachen investiert, auch wenn das jetzt nicht unbedingt grade äh.
Sind das denn dreihundert.
Die Alternative wäre.
Das wäre aber doch bei zwölf Cent, äh das wäre noch nicht mal zwölf Cent. Hatte achtzig.
Oder waren's dreihunderttausend pro Monat.
Ich denke eher achtzig Millionen mal zwölf Cent gleich durch dreißig Tage.
Ja doch, hast recht, hast recht, hast recht, hast recht, hast recht, hast recht. Ich habe hm mich da wieder um mehrere Faktoren vertan.
Dann doch mehrere,
Zwei nämlich.
Dann nochmal ein paar Nullen. Also ähm,
Der nächste Punkt, diese Verordnung äh müssen natürlich nicht durch den Bundestag, denn eine Verordnung kommt aus der Kopf von der Exekutive, deswegen ist es eine Verordnung und kein Gesetz,
Hinweis hier von Andre, der habe ich also Quatsch erzählt. Und dann noch äh nochmal zu den U-Booten, über die wir ja schon ein bisschen gesprochen haben. Ähm.
Ich denke, also wenn so ein, wenn jemand diesen Aufwand betreibt, ich habe da gestern Abend nochmal mit Clemens drüber gesprochen, ja, Clemens Schrimpe,
in allen Fragen äh natürlich derjenige, äh
den man fragen möchte, was solche, was solche Sachen angeht, weil der solche Kabel auch schon mal gesehen hat. Und äh Clemens sagte dazu so, also theoretisch könnte er sich vorstellen, dass es unter Laborbedingungen möglich wäre, äh so ein ähm
so ein Kabel irgendwie anzuzapfen, ja? Und ähm.
Dass es wahrscheinlich auch mit sehr, sehr viel Geld äh theoretisch äh denkbar wäre, das mit einem äh mit einem U-Boot äh zu machen
Aber natürlich eine technische, sehr große Herausforderung ist und wir waren es, glaube ich, darüber einig, dass dass man das zumindest nicht
macht bei Kabeln, die ohnehin bei einem selbst am Festland schon liegen. Also beispielsweise, dass dieses äh vierzehn, was irgendwie fünf Stationen in UK allein hat,
da braucht man dann nicht mehr mit einem U-Boot dran zu tauchen, ja, also in einem ich kann mir vorstellen, im jetzt im Krisenkriegs- und Spionagefall,
Mächten, wo man nicht ans Kabel kommt, sagen wir mal, Kabel, was von Feind eins äh durchs Meer zu Feind zwei geht, da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass man dann dieses
diesen Aufwand auf sich nimmt, da mit einem U-Boot dran zu tauchen, aber die Verbindung zwischen Europa und den USA ähm
werden vermutlich eher da äh abgehört, wo sie äh hergestellt werden und nicht äh auf Vorsee.
Spaßfakt, das größte Risiko für diese Kabel waren äh lange Zeit Haie, weil,
das muss ich nur kurz erzählen.
Weil die sich da einfach verbissen haben.
In dem Kabel seid ihr ein Lichtleiter so, dann ist da sind da tausend Schichten Isolation und ein bisschen Strom drin, weil da ja zwischendurch Stationen zur Verstärkung und so wieder irgendwie verstärkt werden, äh äh versorgt werden müssen mit Energie,
Und ähm jetzt läuft also quasi ein bisschen Strom mit in diesem in diesem dicken Lichtleiter, der dann irgendwie tausendfach isoliert ist und so, ne? Und Haie äh haben ja einen äh ein Sinnesorgan für minimale Strom-Aktivität
im im Wasser. Elektromagnetismus, weil sie, weil Neuronen ja so äh funktionieren, ja? Und so entdecken sie quasi Lebewesen und wissen, wo sie reinbeißen müssen,
Kabel.
Hm, Seeschlange, lecker, eine richtig große.
So und dann ist es, also das jetzt äh so will es dann die Geschichte, dass halt die ersten Kabel, die sie da versenkt haben, da hingen halt andauernd irgendwelche Haie dran und äh haben sich dann die Kabel dann durchgelnagt, ja, weil sie irgendwie dachten, er ist immer noch nicht tot. Ähm,
kleine Spaß, Fakt, wie äh was was wir da gestern Abend erzählt hat, aber hat natürlich mit Spionage überhaupt nichts zu tun und ähm,
ja ich fand die Geschichte nur ganz gut. Also es war dann so manchmal sind die technischen Herausforderungen eben nochmal ganz andere wenn man sagt wir legen jetzt mal ein paar Meter Kabel durch den Teich.
Alles nicht so einfach. So, jetzt fangen wir an.
Jetzt geht's weiter mit mit äh Snowden.
Okay, unsere Boulevard, unsere beliebtes Boulevard-Magazin. Lokbuchnetzpolitik.
Ja. Und zwar und zwar ähm.
Ja, es ging ja richtig zur Sache irgendwie. Vor allem wollen wir gleich mit Equador da loslegen.
Also letzter Stand in der letzten Sendung war ja, dass die USA gesagt haben, ey äh Ecuador, wenn ihr euch da nicht nach unserem Vorstellung unterhalte, äh äh verhaltet, dann äh kündigen wir dieses Freihandelsabkommen, was wir mit euch haben.
Genau, da gab's irgendwie so einen Senator, der irgendwie groß rumge äh spuckt hat und der haben halt irgendwie gleich die ganz große Keule ausge
packt, ohne dass eigentlich bisher irgendwas passiert war, weil es war gab keinen Asylantrag, zumindest keiner wusste niemand von irgendeinem und äh so weiter,
Ja, der Korea.
Hat da irgendwie ganz gnadenlos drauf reagiert und hat dieses Handelsabkommen, was da eben angedroht wurde, dass es denn doch gekündigt werden könnte von den USA, einfach selber gekündigt,
nach dem Motto ihr verarscht uns nicht so und egal.
Wenn ich's richtig gelesen habe, ist es so, dass das ohnehin äh bald ausgelaufen wäre.
Ja, hätte dann neu verhandelt werden müssen.
Genau, also ist jetzt nicht so, dass hier gerade was frisch äh und tolles, ähm da gleich wieder zu Grabe getragen haben,
Das kommt wohl irgendwie der Blumenindustrie da ganz gut äh zu Gute,
auf jeden Fall schon mal äh auch ein Zeichen,
wie groß das Maß an Verärgerung ist, äh in Südamerika und das hat sich ja durch die heutigen Ereignisse dann auch gleich nochmal verstärkt auf eine interessante Art und Weise.
Also zu dieser, zu diesem Freihandelsabkommen, es ist natürlich, es ist ein.
Es ist ein eventuell überzogener Schritt von Equador, nur weil irgendein beknackter Senator äh da irgendwelchen Unsinn redet, sofort so ein Handelsabkommen äh zu kündigen. Ich finde es aber grundsätzlich erstmal einen wichtigen Schritt, sich von.
Also sich auch nur von der Androhung einer Erpressung auf diesem Weg sofort äh äh freizumachen, ja.
Das ist äh leider natürlich für Equadols ein riesen, also eigentlich ist diese die brauchen dieses Handelsabkommen. Äh
weil das also hauptsächlich wie gesagt die Blumenindustrie betrifft
andererseits Equador hat aber auch den den US-Dollar als Hauptzahlungsmittel, das heißt, sie sind auf den Handel mit den USA sehr angewiesen. Und das ist schon ein ähm,
Ein sehr mutiger und unter Umständen nicht besonders schlauer Schritt, den Equador da gemacht hat,
Aber äh einer, der äh mein absoluten Respekt und Anerkennung hat, ich würde mir so viel ähm Cojones bei deutschen Politikern äh,
wünschen, aber es ging ja dann noch weiter, weil Ecuador hat dann den USA Entwicklungshilfe angeboten. Haben gesagt, wir haben hier dreiundzwanzig Millionen Dollar.
Die geben wir euch als Entwicklungshilfe, aber die sind, die sind zweckgebunden,
müsst ihr für Menschenrechtstrainings ausgeben. Das finde ich schon echt.
Das finde ich schon äh, ich meine, das ist natürlich, das kann man nur noch als das kann jeder Diplomaten nur noch als Beleidigung nehmen, ja, das ist äh ähm
Ich weiß nicht, wie weit Equador sich da aus dem äh aus dem Fenster lehnt und sage ich mal außenpolitischen Schaden
für innenpolitischen äh innenpolitisches Kapital äh in Kauf nimmt. Andererseits äh ist es natürlich so, dass diese diese äh Länder in der
unter den unter den USA auf der Landkarte äh sich ausreichend auf der Nase rumtanzen lassen von von den USA,
Und dass da auch mal erfrischend ist, dass überhaupt irgendjemand den USA da mal entgegentritt und sagt, äh leckt uns am Arsch.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist halt, wie schon andeutete, ne. Das ist ja schon ein längerer Trend in Südamerika, der ganze Kontinent emanzipiert sich von den USA, zunehmend,
ganz stark natürlich in Brasilien so aber es gibt halt einfach da überhaupt so 'ne extreme Unzufriedenheit mit dem Einfluss den die USA nimmt auf so vielen Ebenen und das spiegelt sich natürlich in diesen ganzen Sachen wieder.
Ähm in dem Zusammenhang hatte ich gerade schon angedeutet, dass wieder was vorgefallen ist. Äh frischer Bericht äh,
evomoralisch, ja.
Der.
Der Präsident von Bolivien wurde.
Tja, wie soll ich sagen, abgefangen ist nicht die richtige Bezeichnung, aber auf einem Rückflug von einer Konferenz von Moskau.
Wohl in seinem Heimatland, haben Frankreich, Italien und Portugal und Spanien die Überflugrechte äh sozusagen gecancelt,
und dass die Maschine gezwungen in Wien zu landen. Und es gab wohl irgendwie die Vermutung, dass der Snoden an Bord wäre.
War er aber wohl nicht.
Ja.
Das ist schon
wirklich eine ganz harte Nummer. Also sowas äh äh gab's so äh äh in der Form überhaupt nicht. Eine eine große, große, peinliche Nummer, ja, äh also
Da fragt man sich auch wirklich, wer bitte ist, jetzt hier die Triebfeder. Klingt natürlich so ein bisschen so, als ob da auch die USA rumtelefoniert haben. Ich mache, deute das mal so,
dass der politische Druck.
Absurderweise auf Europa, obwohl es gerade Europa auch selber äh ne so zu den zu den Angriffsstaaten gehört, ist wohl enorm groß.
Da kommen wir glaube ich noch ein bisschen zu im Verlauf der äh der Geschichte, die wir äh die wir hier so in unserer Chronistenpflicht äh ein bisschen äh benennen müssen,
weil in Equador geht's ja weiter. Die haben ja gleichzeitig haben die ähm,
ein bisschen Knatsch intern. Und ähm,
Jetzt war irgendwie die Frage, woher hatte der ähm Druck mal Apfel R übrigens auf deiner Übersicht da? Woher, wie kam überhaupt der ähm wie kam überhaupt der äh,
Ähm der Snowden.
Die Ausreise zustande.
Aus Hongkong nach Moskau, weil er hat ja eigentlich gar keinen Pass mehr. Und jetzt stellte sich raus,
es gab eine Andeutung schon in der, in dieser in einem dieser Wiki League Pressestatements das Wiki Leaks ihm geholfen hätte,
Reisepapiere zu bekommen. Und es scheint wohl so gewesen zu sein, dass Julio nachts um vier aus seiner Botschaft den Konsul
angerufen hat in in England mit dem Namen wie heißt der denn? Fahrer des, ich hab mir das hier irgendwo notiert.
Equadurianischen Konsulven, Konsulat.
Genau und hat gesagt, hier, der Mann ist in äh der Mann ist in Lebensgefahr, der braucht sofort irgendwie einen Safepass. Und ähm.
Ärgerlich warum. Ich hatte mir das extra hier rauskopiert. Ähm,
Und was passiert? Der der Konsul sagt, ja, okay, äh Fidel Nervis. Narvis sagt, okay, machen wir.
Und hilft damit tatsächlich dann dem äh dem Snowden da von Hong Kong nach äh zunächst Moskau zu fliegen,
und gleichzeitig gibt dann eben Julio damit auch noch öffentlich an, dass er das organisiert hat. Ja? Und da ist natürlich klar, dass Ecuador dann irgendwann sagt, ey, habt ihr eigentlich ein äh habt ihr, hast du irgendwie einen Knall?
Ja.
Unseren äh unseren äh Konsul hier zu verarschen und dann noch irgendwie ähm da.
Wieso hört denn der überhaupt auf ihn, also das ist.
Es war ein ein guter Mann, der äh offensichtlich da das also so oder so hat jetzt äh Korea schon gesagt, also der Raphael Korea, ähm schon gesagt, dass der ähm,
Narvis. Äh da durchaus mit Konsequenzen rechnen muss,
gleichzeitig ist aber sagen die äh Equarianer und die sind da offensichtlich sehr auf ihre Souveränität bedacht, wie man merkt, ja äh und die haben halt auch keinem äh Lust äh auf den A Sanchez, der da irgendwie den Zampano macht.
Und ähm so deuten das jetzt die Artikel an, dass da bei denen auch inzwischen der Haussegen ein bisschen,
schief hängt und die Equarianer wohl auch schon so durch die Blumen zu verstehen gegeben haben. Julio äh auch in unserer Botschaft
ne, genießt du hier Gastfreundschaft und äh Gäste gehen halt auch irgendwann wieder und du kannst gerne gehen, wenn dir das hier nicht gefällt. Ähm so steht's auf jeden Fall dann äh durch die Blume in den,
in den Artikeln. Das heißt, die äh äh Ecuador hat jetzt relativ offen,
die äh den schwarzen Snowden, dem äh den den Russen zugeschoben und hat gesagt, okay, wir haben diesen Safe-Pass äh jetzt gecancelt, der ist auch nicht mehr gültig,
und der sitzt jetzt bei euch in Russland und wenn der bei uns Asyl beantragen möchte, dann muss er das bitte auf unserem Boden tun.
Wobei unklar ist, ähm ob ob als ihr Boden dann auch die ähm Botschaft gelten würde.
Nee, das ist nicht unklar, das ist so.
Nee, aber ob da auch die Botschaft gelten würde, ja? Also der muss auf auf deren Territorium kommen, um Asyl zu beantragen. Das ist klar, dann also.
Also eine Botschaft in einem anderen Land ist, ist sozusagen Territorium des Staates. Wenn du in so eine Botschaft reinmarschierst, dann bist du in einem anderen Land.
Jetzt kommt der äh Julio äh der der äh Eduardo, da aber natürlich nicht hin ohne Hilfe der Russen,
weil Ecuador ihm sogar dieses Safe-Pass Dorkiment äh also diesen dieses diese Freireiseschein
den äh Geleitschein oder wie auch immer so was dann heißt, äh gecancelt hat. So, das heißt Ecuador hat jetzt erstmal äh so den,
den stärksten Rückzug gemacht, den sie machen konnten und haben das Problem in russische Hände übergeben.
Hm.
Während, oh das war ja, es es ist so es ist so spannend, ja? Während die USA dann bei ihren in ihren ganzen Armee-Basen den Guardian sperren, weil die Dokumente sind ja nach wie vor geheim.
Und deswegen dürfen die Soldaten auch nicht übers Internet äh dort drauf.
Ja.
Ja. So, so jetzt ich ich gehe das alles mal äh von der Chronologie her durch, ja? Und.
Dann ähm wird auf einmal die EU-Bespitzelung bekannt und.
Geheimdokumente belegen, dieser diese Artikel erschien dann auch im Spiegel zum ersten Mal. Das,
Die NSA irgendwie EU-Vertretung verwandt hat
Computersysteme infiltriert hat, irgendwelche Fernwartbaren, Telefonanlagen da regelmäßig angerufen hat und irgendwie unkonfiguriert hat und solche Scherze, also grob einfach mal in mehreren,
in mehreren Ländern, also äh sowohl auf dem US-Boden als auch in äh in den ich,
Brüssel oder äh Straßburg oder wo das dann war in genau in Brüssel diese Telefonanlage. Alles einfach infiltrieren.
Und die EU überwachen,
gleichzeitig irgendwie Deutschland dann als Partner bezeichnen, also mit dem nur äh eine auf eine bestimmte Weise äh,
geheimdienstliche Zusammenarbeit stattfindet und so. Also sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr übel, aber ich sehe dann nirgendwo,
Also ich sehe immer nur diese Artikel und sehe da wenig bei Belege und so, deswegen das gesamte Ausmaß und die technischen Hintergründe sind da noch irgendwie unklar, deswegen will ich mich da gar nicht so groß zu äußern, aber äh.
USA überwachen die EU. Und das natürlich äh dann schon ein bisschen.
Ja, da merkt man auch, dass den Politikern, dass es auf einmal, äh, auf einmal wachen sie auf, so, ja, äh, wie, nicht nur uns auch, ja, ich dachte, überwacht nur die Bürger. Genau. Ja. So, uns auch, oh Gott.
Und Hans-Peter Friedrich, ne, der sich letzte Woche noch den DIN die Naivität und den Anti-Amerikanismus äh äh.
Geschrieben hat.
Und sagt jetzt also wenn dieser Verdacht sich bestätigen sollte.
Dann wäre eine Entschuldigung unausweichlich.
Oh Gott. Er er droht offen, er droht offen mit einem nachhaltigen und entschiedenen.
Es geht noch weiter in Deutschland äh oder EU, Deutschland und USA, die sind ja, die handeln ja andauernd irgendwelche Abkommen aus, ja? Und dann sagt er, wenn die Meldungen stimmen, dann ist das Vertrauensverhältnis belastet.
Und es wird in vielen Bereichen des Europäisch-amerikanischen Verhältnisses zu Verzögerungen kommen.
Also er sah, weil das Vertrauen erstmal wiederhergestellt werden muss. Das sagt so, also was ist das denn bitte? So, also jetzt müsst ihr euch aber wirklich mal entschuldigen,
Weil sonst müssen wir jetzt mal kurz die Verhandlung aussetzen. Weißt du, wie irgendwie mit der Türkei, weißt du? Solang.
Eine Woche später.
Solange ihr, solange ihr irgendwie da Tränengas auf die Leute schießt, können wir nicht weiter über euren EU Beitritt
äh äh diskutieren. Macht das erstmal zu Ende, dann können wir weiterreden. Und genauso stellt sich der stellt sich der Friedriche, nachdem irgendwie klar ist, dass die USA irgendwie die Souveränität des Landes irgendwie oder ganzen Staatengemeinschaften da irgendwie,
mit Füßen treten und Regierungen abholen, sagt er, na da werden wir jetzt erstmal ähm,
muss jetzt erstmal irgendwie eine Entschuldigung schreiben, ja, bevor wir weiter äh euch in den Arsch kriechen. Also ist wirklich ähm
wirklich erbärmlich und wir kommen da gleich dann noch so einen Lauf in die Geschichte. Wie gesagt, ist lang. Äh kommen da gleich nochmal zu, äh was da vielleicht auch nochmal Hintergründe sein können.
Ähm wie gesagt, in diplomatische Vertretung, in EU und Washington wurden also von von der NSA äh
infiziert Räumlichkeiten der EU äh in der in Washington wurden irgendwie äh verwandst, äh E-Mails, Dokumente, auf Computern nachgelesen, also komplett das, was du machst, äh wenn du, wenn du wirklich ein.
Wenn du wirklich einen Feind hast und,
zu dieser in also Deutschland sagt da irgendwie relativ wenig zu sagen, nach wie vor so, ja, wir müssen irgendwie gucken und vorsichtig sein und wenn das wirklich stimmt, dann wäre das natürlich echt ein Afro, ja.
Denkst dir was ist denn mit denen los? Also was ist denn bitte,
Okay, ne und äh dann äh sagte Friedrich sagt, also da müsst ihr euch aber jetzt echt mal entschuldigen und Trittin sagt, na alles klar, so jetzt sind ja wohl, jetzt können wir ja wohl mal äh dem Snowden Asyl geben,
Und während äh währenddessen in äh in in Moskau ähm lässt der Snowden dann von.
Russischen, diplomaten? Zunächst war die Rede von fünfzehn, dann am Ende von einundzwanzig Asylanträgen,
Äh also lässt die russischen Diplomaten Asylanträge aus dem Transitbereich in die jeweiligen jeweiligen, was habe ich denn heute mit dem STR? Also scheiße ist. Nee, also mit in die jeweiligen ähm,
Botschaften tragen.
Und es gibt wieder ein äh Pressestatement von Wiki Leaks, ja, also ähm es ist da sehr, sehr.
Sehr, sehr traurig, wie wie Wiki League sich da irgendwie verhält und andauernd, also wie Julian Assange sich da verhält und da irgendwie meint, dass das jetzt irgendwie ihrer wäre, ähm gut.
Also ich meine, dass sie sich da jetzt verbunden äh fühlen oder er sich vor allem verbunden fühlt, das äh kann ich ja gut nachvollziehen, so. Ja, obwohl das, ob das aber alles so hilfreich ist, diesen Aufstand äh zu machen. Das ist mir noch nicht so ganz.
Weißt du, wenn dir jemand, wenn dir jemand wirklich helfen möchte? Weil er, weil ihm an dir gelegen ist, dann macht er darüber, dann besteht er nicht darauf, dass die scheiß Pressemitteilung auf seiner Website passieren, sondern.
Naja gut, aber man könnte zumindest argumentieren, dass äh vielleicht
Vielleicht, ja? Äh ohne äh Holio, äh Mister Snowden immer noch in Hong Kong wäre und dann vielleicht auch schon nicht mehr in Hongkong, sondern schon auf dem Weg ganz woanders hin.
Äh das ist richtig der Sinn, also äh das da da sehe ich aber eben den Unterschied zwischen was mache ich und wie mache ich's, ja? Und zu sagen, okay, ich ich riskiere mein Verhältnis zu zu dem einzigen Land dieser Welt, was mir gerade noch Schutz bietet.
Na gut, das ist ja seine eigene Sache.
Das ist
genau, das ist halt echt eine eine coole, ein cooler Move, ja. Da muss man eben auch Anerkennung für geben. Aber irgendwie diese diese Pressemitteilungsnummer, da bei WikiLeaks, das äh ist für mich irgendwie auch so ein das hat für mich einfach einen blöden äh Beigeschmack.
Ja, aber liebe Hörer, ihr merkt, wir loben. Hello. Und wir strafen.
Belohnen. Insgesamt wohlwollende Anerkennung, ja? Vor fördern und fördern.
Exactley.
Was sagt der also ähm nach Österreich? Nach Bolivien, nach Brasilien, nach China, nach Cuba, nach Finnland, nach Frankreich, nach Deutschland, nach Indien, nach Italien,
Irland, Holland, Nicaragua, nur auf äh Polen, äh Russland,
Spanien, Schweiz und Venezuela wurden also jetzt diese Asylanträge äh verteilt. Und ähm was passiert.
Ich frage mich ja jetzt mal ernsthaft, wie bitte diese Liste zustande gekommen ist.
Ich weiß nicht, haben die vielleicht das, äh wir hatten das ja verlinkt, die die Seite von Wikipedia. Ey, das ist einfach ein Streuschuss. Es ist vor allem, finde ich, sehr spannend.
Ja gut, ich meine, wenn da ein Strolch, das hätte machen wollen, dann hätte er einfach jedes Scheißland nehmen können, vielleicht außer den USA und äh äh Hawaii und sowas. Aber ähm ja, ich weiß, Hawaii ist kein eigenständiges Land. Äh,
Die Frage ist, ist in dieser Liste sozusagen was steckt da drin? Also bei wie viel der Länder steckt wirklich eine reale Hoffnung drin? Und bei wie viel der Länder ist äh ist eher so eine Trolllage, genau. Also ich meine, Deutschland,
so keine Ahnung, wie gut der sich da auskennt, aber das war dann doch eher unwahrscheinlich, dass äh äh die Deutschen da an der Stelle drehen, weil den Stress wollen sie sich bestimmt nicht geben, mit den Niederlanden, denke ich mal, sieht das da ganz genauso aus,
die südamerikanischen Staaten wiederum sind dann eigentlich alle vertreten, ist da Bolivien, ja, nee. Doch. Wo denn?
Äh um nach Österreich. Ich so, ja, okay. Nehmen wir mal.
Ach so, ja, okay. Bolivien auch. Ach so, ja okay, deswegen sind sie jetzt auch so durchgedreht, wegen dem Morales, ja. Stier.
So und jetzt sagt er also, äh in in Deutschland war diese Geschichte ja relativ schnell erledigt. Ich glaube, morgens war die Meldung, äh Deutschland hat das äh hat den Antrag bekommen
und auch da ist natürlich das Problem, er kann einen Asylantrag erst auf deutschem Boden,
stellen und die äh was, wo nachher dann also fragte, war quasi ein ein Aufenthaltsrecht oder so, dass er überhaupt erstmal auf deutschem Boden könne, um,
Diesen Antrag zu stellen und da wurde also von Deutschland jetzt gesagt, ja, Entschuldigung, da sind die Voraussetzungen sind nicht erfüllt. Ohne nähere Begründung, ja. Ähm
Das heißt, die die heiße Kartoffel wollte Deutschland dann doch erstmal nicht entgegennehmen. Ähm
Fun fact. Irgendwann kam dann noch die Meldung, das war dann echt also da war ich dann echt mal überrascht, ja. Ähm es gibt ja den den äh Bosbach, ne. Der Boßbach ist ja derjenige,
Ähm der äh ich glaube dem Innenausschuss,
äh vorsitzt noch heute. Und das ist so jemand, weißt du, du hast eine Flutkatastrophe, dann ruft der Deutschland Radio morgens beim Bosbach an, der ist immer früh wach, deswegen ist der um sechs Uhr schon im Radio. Ähm.
Genau Vorsitzender des Innenausschusses des Deutschen Bundestags und.
Der Bosbach, weißte, haste Flutkatastrophe, dann sagt der Bosbach, ja und wir sehen, wie die Menschen jetzt aus ihren Häusern vertrieben werden, ähm wir brauchen Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Du hast irgendwie,
Kind wird vom Hund gebissen.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ja? Und der stellt sich jetzt hin und sagt, äh äh der der Rechtsstaat muss gerettet werden. Ja, also so schlimm ist das, was die USA machen, ja. Fiel mir nur so am Rande auf,
Aber okay, also das das nur das war war erwähnenswert, dass selbst der Bosbach. Also man müsste da jetzt da.
In welcher Form will er denn das retten?
Na, das ist also äh äh ich habe das grade, wo ist denn die.
Dieser Link führt nicht dahin, wo er hingehört, ne?
Nö, das ist eher so ein Generrick irgendwie Nachrichten des Tages, Link, das ist wahrscheinlich alles schon wieder rausge.
Ja, das ist das, ich vermute ja.
Webseite, auf die du hier gelinkt hast, da.
Wechseln, die haben ja keine.
Nein, weil das wo kommen wir denn da hin, wenn die Nachrichten von gestern dann irgendwann noch irgendwie.
Ja, cool. Ja, also wenn du da, wenn du da auf die Nachricht von gestern lenkst, dann siehst.
Aber das wäre jetzt für mich auch ein bisschen zu schockierend, äh das, glaube ich, nachzulesen.
Ja, gut, aber.
Für den Rechtsstaat, was kommt als nächstes?
Jetzt kommt erst, jetzt kommt das richtig Schöne. Jetzt jetzt liegt also also das da Putin, ich bin ja begeistert von dem Mann, ne. Jetzt.
Kriegt Russland auch diesen Asylantrag, ja? Der Snowden ist zu dem Zeitpunkt seit acht, neun, zehn Tagen, bei denen im Transit, ich weiß nicht genau, wie lange der jetzt bei denen da sitzt, ne? Und wir hatten ja schon über die Räume für Spezialbehandlungen gesprochen
weil er ja nicht mit dem Schlafsack auf den Wartebecken schläft, also sitzt er irgendwo hinten mit dem, wie heißt der KGB, jetzt FSB, ne?
Und ähm ne, trifft sich offensichtlich ja mit Diplomaten, die seine äh Dinger da wegtragen und so. Und in dieser Situation, ja, nachdem der Putin den seit ein paar Tagen da sitzen hat,
ne? Tritt der Putin vor die Kamera und sagt.
Also wir haben hier einen ähm jetzt einen Asylantrag gestellt bekommen von dem Edward Snowden. Und ähm,
kann natürlich bei uns bleiben, aber.
Wir wir haben ja noch nie jemanden weggeschickt.
Wir haben noch nie jemanden weggeschickt, vor allem nicht in den Tod, also Russland liefert nicht aus, der Mann kann bei uns.
In den USA gibt's ja die Todesstrafe. Das würde ich sagen. Nee, warte, aber es wird ja noch viel schöner. Schon jetzt so schön.
Nee, warte, aber es wird ja noch viel schöner. Und dann sagt der Putin, ähm der kann bei uns bleiben, aber ich stelle ihm eine Bedingung. Er darf nichts weiter veröffentlichen.
Er darf unserem Partner, den USA, nicht weiter schaden. Das ist wirklich so krass geil.
Und jetzt ist denkt man natürlich so, also,
das ist halt das ist ich weiß halt nicht, ob das jetzt Schach oder Poker ist. Also es ist eigentlich Poker, weil natürlich die Überlegung ist, also was jeder daraus liest, ist Putin weiß alles,
Und der Informationsvorsprung, den ihr durch das, was Norden ihm jetzt potenziell erzählt hat, hat strategisch.
Der ist natürlich zunichte, wenn's jetzt alle anderen wissen. Deswegen ist natürlich nicht in Putins Interesse, dass Norden weiter veröffentlicht. Weil dieses gesamte Wissen, wenn's Norden ihm etwas erzählt hat.
Ihm was erzählt ist, glaube ich.
Das weiß man nicht, deswegen sage ich ja, ist halt Poker, ja, aber dieser dieser äh.
Nee, ich glaube, also ich würde das anders lesen. Ich lese das so. Er sagt halt, ja, du kannst bleiben, aber nur, wenn du jetzt irgendwie lieb bist. Setz dich hier in so ein Landhaus, ja, Russland, wir haben eine Menge Platz, ist sehr schön bei uns.
Heißt doch überhaupt nicht in seinem Interesse. Sein Interesse ist doch natürlich alles zu wissen über die geheimdienstlichen Aktivitäten der.
Aber hier geht es nicht dadrum, hier geht's überhaupt nicht dadrum, was sie mit Snowden machen oder nicht machen. Ich meine, wenn er in seinem scheiß Land ist, dann machen die sowieso mit ihm was,
So, ja? Äh ich denke, fürs Snowden geht's jetzt auch erstmal dadrum, einfach überhaupt mal einen Ort zu finden, der nicht so einen Flughafen äh ist.
Ja aber wieso welches Interesse hat den.
Was ich sagen wollte, ist sein sein Angebot war halt ein ein Angebot, was zwar nach außen hin sowohl den USA irgendwie den Schneid abkauft, so nach dem Motto ja,
Ja, ihr wisst ja, wir wir können ja nicht an euch ausliefern, weil ihr so böse seid, so, aus dem Scheiß nur auf euch. Aber wir haben euch mal ganz offiziell mal ganz lieb,
Ja, so, weil wenn er dann hier ist, dann hält er auch das Maul. Macht er natürlich nicht. Weiß Putin natürlich auch,
ein Angebot gemacht hat, dass der sowieso nicht annehmen kann. Also, ach so, na du willst das Asyl nicht haben, na dann, wir haben's probiert.
Ja, tut uns leid, sorry. Dann können wir da wohl nichts machen.
Oder Snowden sagt, ich äh veröffentliche nicht weiter, nimmt das Asylland vor und dann schmeißt Blut in ihn auch nicht mehr raus.
Dann kann er sagen, dann kann er sich wie der Friedrich hinstellen und sagen, also bevor wir nochmal weiter mit dem Snowden zusammenarbeiten, muss der jetzt echt eine Entschuldigung schreiben. Da wird's jetzt mehrere Wochen Verzögerungen geben in der Zusammenarbeit.
Ja, ist unklar.
Ich, ich, ich glaube, ich bin da echt äh ich glaube, der Move äh von von Putin ist hier eher einfach mal äh äh diplomatisch durchblicken zu lassen. Ähm ich habe mich mit dem Unterhalten,
und ich weiß jetzt alles,
ich möchte eigentlich nicht, dass er es veröffentlicht, aber okay. Äh auf jeden Fall ist der Move so oder so geil, weil er halt Unmengen an Spekulationen natürlich irgendwie in äh ins Feld führt so, ne? Und äh hat er, hat der Putin, hat der Putin cool gemacht?
Gut. Waren wir durch mit unseren Boulevardteilen.
Ja, wir kommen jetzt zu dem.
Wir kommen jetzt zu dem nochmals zu dem zu der zu insbesondere dem Verhältnis der USA und Deutschland.
Und zwar hatte das der,
Andy, in dem Chaos-Radio denn schon auch angedeutet oder nicht nur angedeutet, sondern auch detailliert äh behandelt, dass,
Es einen bestimmten Grund dafür gibt oder einen historischen Zusammenhang, warum Deutschland sich so von den USA ähm,
in diesem Fall,
So natürlich irgendwie unter dem, unter der Hand der USA steht. Man muss sich das vorstellen irgendwie Deutschland verliert äh äh zum Glück den zweiten Weltkrieg
und äh wie alle wissen, war ja dann danach die Situation der äh der Kalte Krieg zwischen den beiden großen Mächten äh USA und äh UDSSR
Und ähm was die USA musste jetzt irgendwie sich überlegen, was machen wir mit diesem Land Deutschland, ne? Wir möchten einerseits nicht, dass das äh
dass es äh irgendwie wieder in so eine Nazi äh Richtung geht,
andererseits müssen wir irgendwie sicherstellen, dass das dass dieses Land jetzt nicht irgendwie kommunistisch wird, ja? Und.
Aus äh wie machen wir das? Wir,
berichten da irgendwie so eine so eine freie Welt ein. Wir machen ein buntes Westberlin und so, ne, sehen zu, dass äh dass da irgendwie der der die Vorzüge des Kapitalismus irgendwie besonders zur Geltung kommen in diesem Land
aber irgendwie müssen wir natürlich dann einen Finger draufhalten und da machen wir erstmal von vorneherein äh ein paar Geheimverträge, dass wir dieses Land,
ausführlich äh überwachen und kontrollieren, dass da nichts äh gegen unsere Interessen läuft, ja? Und aus naheliegenden Gründen brauchten sie natürlich dann äh,
für diesen, für diese Überwachung des Landes äh deutsches Personal, das hatten sie ja gar nicht. Ja, sie waren ja, sie hatten vielleicht ein bisschen
äh äh im militärischen Bereich äh Geheimdienstler, die die Überwachung von Deutschen vorgenommen haben. Du hast ja noch vor kurzem dieses ähm, dass es in einem anderen Podcast, glaube ich, auch erzählt, dieses äh Museum da äh besucht?
Ja, also aber trotzdem, um jetzt irgendwie so die gesamte deutsche Bevölkerung zu überwachen, äh waren die Amis ja jetzt noch nicht so wirklich.
Äh äh aufgestellt und haben dann natürlich gesagt, Adenauer, das müssen wir irgendwie zusammen machen, ne. Und fangen an, ähm da,
eine Bundesrepublik aufzubauen, die sie geheimdienstlich sehr stark unter Kontrolle haben,
Dann wurden in den Fünfzigerjahren die Pariser Verträge da verhandelt, wo dann dieses, wo dann die Besatzung eigentlich weg sollte und die BRD dann wirklich auch souverän wurde,
Und da wurde dann auch wurde Deutschland dann eben abgerungen, dass es bestimmte ähm
Sonderregelungen für geheimdienstliche Kontrolle gibt, Notstand, Angriffsfall und so. Wir wissen, nachher kam dann noch dieser ganze NATO-Kram und so. Und sie verpflichten jeweils in jedem einzelnen Schritt Deutschland zu einer engen,
die nachrichtendienstlichen Kooperation.
Und das ist jetzt erstmal nicht nur äh nicht nur die USA, sondern natürlich auch die anderen, weil die anderen Alliierten, also äh,
Großbritannien und Frankreich. Äh die natürlich auch keinen Bock hatten, dass sie wieder in die in Europa so ein starkes Deutschland haben. Also auch die haben ein sehr starkes Interesse dieses Land dann eben äh zu überwachen. Anfangs machen's die Briten ganz besonders.
Und ähm.
Dann kommen irgendwie in neunzehnhundertfünfundfünfzig werden mehrere geheime Memorandi of Understanding ausgetauscht
die jetzt dann fünfzig Jahre später irgendwie äh nicht mehr der Geheimhaltung unterlagen und durch einen Historiker
untersucht wurden. Also dieses, alles, was ich jetzt äh so grob zusammenfasse, äh ist eben von dem Historiker namens Forsche-Poot in einem in einem Buch, was schon zweitausendzwölf erschien,
so äh dokumentiert worden,
Und da äh geht's dann wieder um die äh in, wo dann wieder den Westmächten die äh geheime Überwachung zu gebilligt wird von Deutschland, ja?
Und neunzehnhundertdreiundsechzig gab's dann äh Enthüllung über das, dass die BRD überhaupt einen äh krassen Inlandsgeheimdienst hat und was was für Aktivitäten der so vornimmt. Verfassungsschutz, ja?
Ähm.
Wie, dass es überhaupt einen hat. Das war bis zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ob's ob's nicht also vom, also da bin ich jetzt nicht ganz hundertprozentig im Bilder, ob's klar war, auf jeden Fall das, was sie gemacht haben, war verfassungswidrig.
Und ja wie, ne, weil wie klar ist. Äh kurze Sidenote an der Stelle, es gibt äh du hast als Start immer ein Inlandsgeheimnis, in einen Auslandsgeheimdienst,
Inlandsgeheimdienst überwacht so deine eigene Bevölkerung,
auf äh Strömung, äh die irgendwie äh dem dem Staatswesen entgegenstehen, ist aber getrennt von der Polizei, das heißt du du sammelst da wirklich Intelligence
und äh sammelst also äh sammelst geheimdienstliche Informationen über die Bevölkerung, um eben da äh feindliche Strömungen zu entdecken, ja? Verfassungsschutz nennt sie das deshalb, ja? Oder in Deutschland, das deshalb. Und dann hast du den Auslandsgeheimdienst, der also guckt
äh wie infiltrieren wir die anderen Staaten um zu gucken, dass sie keinen Scheiß bauen oder beziehungsweise um zu gucken, was die so bauen, dass wir das auch bauen können, ja? Das.
Was die so für Scheiß bauen, damit wir die gleichen Scheiß bauen können.
Spionage ist natürlich da auch ein äh ein wichtiger Punkt. So ähm neunzehnhundertachtundsechzig gab's dann erst das G zehn Gesetz,
das den Geheimdiensten eine gesetzliche Grundlage bietet,
Und auch dann diese G zehn Kommission des Bundestages parlamentarische Kontrolle und so in Kraft setzt, ja?
Erst dann hatte Deutschland offiziell seine beiden Geheimdienste, Inland- und Auslandsgeheimdienst, Verfassung, Verfassungsschutz und äh BND und beide haben in den Geheimverträgen strenge Kooperationsverpflichtungen ähm,
den mit den äh alliierten Mächten und insbesondere in den USA,
und die Geschichte, die jetzt da von mehreren erzählt wird, also einmal von Egon Bahr und Andi hat das im Chaos-Radio auch nochmal vor äh von einem anderen engen Vertrauten eines äh Bundeskanzlers äh der BRD äh,
erzählt, dass die also da ich nicht genau weiß, ob Andy in der Sendung auch gesagt hat, welcher Bundeskanzler lasse ich das jetzt mal außen voraus, weil der andere,
Ja, eine große Bekannte, deutscher Bundeskanzler und äh da wird also dann äh.
Erzählt, dass die also quasi so ja hallo, wir sind jetzt Bundeskanzler und dann kommen irgendwie die äh USA,
vorbei und sagen, ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch und ähm
Ihnen ist ja sicherlich klar, dass wir hier diese Geheimverträge haben und ähm wir wollen nochmal bitteschön dafür sorgen, dass ihre Politik
uns da jetzt nicht zu diplomatischen Verstimmungen führt. Ich habe ihnen da mal hier nochmal eine Kopie mitgebracht, was der Adenauer uns da mehrfach unterschrieben hat. Und äh wir wollen ja keinen Ärger haben,
freuen wir uns doch auf eine gute Zusammenarbeit, ja, wo dann äh in der in der
sowie Egon Badi Geschichte erzählt, äh Willy Brandt, dann natürlich irgendwie sehr äh sehr wütend war, aber auch er dann irgendwann sagen muss, okay, hier so ist es jetzt und da muss ich jetzt,
mitspielen. Das heißt, diese ähm.
Diese geheim geheime Zusammenarbeit der Geheimdienste muss so weitergeführt werden, sonst geht's hier schief.
Fällt mir wieder diese großartige Quote ein von Bill Hix, sagt dir das was?
Leider viel zu früh verstorbener äh ja Stand-up-Comedian und extrem,
scharfzündiger politischer Kommentator gewesen, der dann immer so die Situation so ah ein neuer Präsident ist gewählt worden so und dann gleich nach seiner Wahl kommen dann so Geheimdienste irgendwie in den Raum rein und dann.
Die Leinwand runtergefahren, dann zeigen sie ihm so einen Film,
So die Ermordung von John F. Kennedy aus einer Kameraposition, die bisher noch keiner kannte, gezeigt wird. Danach nur.
Ja.
So ein bisschen ist es wahrscheinlich mit dem Bundeskanzler dann auch gewesen so.
Ich also ich.
Es ranken sich da jetzt die Gerüchte drum. Ich habe dieses Buch von Herrn Forsche noch nicht gelesen, in dem kommt natürlich jetzt, obwohl es schon letztes Jahr veröffentlicht wurde, natürlich nochmal eine sehr viel krassere Bedeutung zu, aber ähm,
wie gesagt, mit der deutschen Geschichte und der äh also auch ohne Geheimverträge lässt sich diese äh.
Diese absolute Hölligkeit Deutschlands gegenüber den USA natürlich sehr gut äh sehr gut erklären. Es ist natürlich schon klar, dass,
Also mich hat das eigentlich sowieso schon so als als Jugendlicher immer gewundert, wie Deutschland nachdem es irgendwie sich so was
Also so was gegönnt hat, wie den zweiten Weltkrieg, wie Deutschland,
so schnell wieder eine eine Machtposition äh bekommen konnte in der in der Welt, ja? Also wirtschaftlich ähm die die Vorherrschaft in der EU und so. Das muss ja vielen äh anderen äh Ländern durchaus auch mal ein Dorn im Auge gewesen sein,
und das wäre also ohne die,
ohne die strategische Bedeutung Deutschlands äh für die USA im zweiten äh im im Kalten Krieg so sicherlich nicht äh der Fall gewesen.
Ja, beziehungsweise,
Man wusste ja, dass Deutschland einfach ein äh wirtschaftliches Powerhouse ist und dass man auch am Ende äh mit einem wirtschaftlich erfolgreichen Deutschland bestimmt deutlich weniger Ärger hat, als mit einem nicht so erfolgreichen äh will jetzt hier nicht die Geschichtsklammer zu weit äh aufmachen, aber
Das war ja nun unter anderem auch genau vorher ein Problem zwischen dem ersten und dem zweiten Weltkrieg
dass es eben Deutschland auch so schlecht ging, dass das ja eben genau diese äh Tendenzen gefördert hat, wieder nach dem starken Mann zu rufen, der dann leider auch kam.
Und äh von daher ist dann mit diesen Wirtschaftsförderungsprogrammen einfach ein ganz anderer Weg eingeschlagen worden und der war ja auch relativ erfolgreich. Kann man sagen.
So auf jeden Fall die Hintergründe und das fügt sich zumindest sehr äh sehr schön mit ein in diese wirklich sehr, sehr verhaltenen Reaktionen
Deutschlands auf diesen auf diesen also auf diese Apperaktivität völlig unvorstellbar ja?
Was ich mich ja immer noch frage, ist, das haben wir jetzt auch wenig beleuchtet, vielleicht können wir das in den nächsten Wochen auch nochmal weiter aufgreifen, weil ich glaube, da herrscht auch generell noch Unklarheit, so diese
kolportierte vom Spiegel vor allem berichtete komplette Überwachung von was weiß ich wie viele hundert Millionen Telekommunikationsvorgängen in Deutschland durch die NSA
Insbesondere im Netz, da fragen sich ja grade irgendwie alle und ich habe da auch noch keine guten Antworten gehört, wo denn bitte dieser Abgriff dann,
erfolgt sein soll, ja, äh unter anderem steht da das Dezix grade unter Feuer und äh rudert mit den Armen und meint, äh nö, kann gar nicht sein.
Ja
Gemerkt.
Wie geht's da jetzt hin und her? Also das genau, das war jetzt auch noch ein.
Ja, also das ist so, glaube ich, wissen wir jetzt auch gerade noch nicht so viel dazu. Die Dinge sind derzeit extrem im Fluss, so und äh sicherlich, wenn wir dieses Thema auch in der nächsten Woche wieder aufgreifen.
Ich denke, ich hoffe, dass wir in der nächsten Woche dann ein bisschen klarere äh klares Verständnis dafür haben, wo jetzt überall was abgehört wird. Auf jeden Fall die,
Was in Deutschland in den Dezix, der sich ja als der ein, also auf jeden Fall der größte Internetknotenpunkt in Deutschland,
bezeichnen darf. Ich glaube, die tun das so behaupten so, dass wir ins weltweit, das halte ich aber ja für unwahrscheinlich.
Nee, ich glaube, dass Amis ist dann doch schon noch. Äh da geht dann mehr Daten durch, wobei.
Und.
Jetzt geht's natürlich dann, du liest dann irgendwie so, ja und hier die Dezix-Datenverkehr geht irgendwie an den an den BND für Bedarfsträger. Das sagt dann ein Experte äh gegenüber heiße Online, dann sagt der,
wie und in welchem Ausmaß deutsche Dienste auf die Datenströme in am Dezix zugreifen, darüber darf der dürfen wir laut Gesetz zur Beschränkung des Brief und Pässe,
Post- und Fernmeldegeheimnisses äh keine Auskunft geben und äh dann kommt wieder kommt natürlich wieder Sabine Leutnarrenberger, die dann sagt, äh ne, das war dann diese fünf Prozent äh Problematik, obwohl sie eigentlich zwanzig Prozent dürften. Also,
muss man glaube ich jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen warten bis sich die wie sagt man das denn? Nebel.
Der Staub gelegt.
Der Staub gelegt hat, ja, bis man dann.
Label verzogen.
Der Nebel verzogen der. Deswegen.
Erstmal weniger äh in dieser Folge weniger darüber wie jetzt technisch wo genau was abgegriffen wird.
Gut. Nächstes Thema, wenn ich die beiden da gerade sehe, sollten wir das vielleicht mal umdrehen.
Ah okay, machen wir.
Davon hab ich jetzt gar nichts gehört.
Ja, interessante, interessante äh hm interessante Meldung am Rande. Das geht jetzt gerade so ein bisschen unter. Ähm.
Ein Isländischer.
Mithelfer von Wiki Leaks namens Tordason,
war äh also er hatte mehrere Jahre für äh Wiki Leaks gearbeitet und hat am Ende äh internes von Wikileaks an den ans FBI gegeben.
Also es war ein enger enger Mitarbeiter von Wiki Leaks, der am Ende sich als äh FBI-Informant betätigt hat. Ähm.
Er war siebzehn, als er äh angeworben wurde wohl vom äh vom FBI und hat deren äh.
IRC äh Server oder sowas verwaltet und hat dann äh.
Schon irgendwie äh sich komisch verhalten, nämlich Wiki Leaks T-Shirts über irgend so ein Onlineshop vertrieben und dieses Geld irgendwie veruntreut.
Ähm.
Und hat dann wohl, nachdem er dann von von WikiLeaks auch rausgeworfen wurde, ähm soll er dann wohl zweitausendelf mit achtzehn Jahren,
das FBI kontaktiert haben und denen irgendwelche Sachen gegeben haben, ja?
Ähm hat irgendwie Auszüge aus privater Kommunikation zwischen sich selber und Julian Assange gezeigt und ähm,
dann das FBI hat ihm wohl irgendwie fünftausend Dollar Belohnung gegeben. Ach so, das war noch Entschuldigung. Äh äh kurz danach äh,
wurde er von WikiLeaks gefeuert, ja? Nicht, nicht kurz davor. Und ähm, dann irgendwie vom vom FBI abgespeist mit irgendwie fünftausend Dollar und dann war das Thema erledigt. Ähm.
Es gibt also jetzt die Meldung lautet einfach erstmal nur, es gibt es gab einen FBI-Informanten im näheren Umfeld Wiki Leaks und man muss jetzt halt mal schauen
wie weit der wirklich ins Vertrauen gezogen wurde. Das scheint nicht besonders äh weit gewesen zu sein, weil schon die ihre Gitter hier, die isländische Parlamentsabgeordnete, die ja auch im Umfeld von Wiki Leaks äh tätig war, schon
ähm,
irgendwie dem nicht vertraut hat und vor ihm gewarnt hat, als er kam. Aber da sehen wir ähm das schnürt sich eine weitere.
Schlinge.
Ja, vor allem eine andere Schlinge sehe ich jetzt hier an der Stelle. Da kann man auch nochmal drauf hinweisen. Also.
Themen vom CCC war ja schon immer auch das junge Hacker zu schützen,
Der Club hat ja so einige schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht.
Direkt im Club, im unmittelbaren Umfeld des äh Klubs, ja, so Geschichten wie.
Mit Karl Koch zum Beispiel auch da gab's eine enge äh Verschlingung mit Medien und mit äh Geheimdiensten, Behörden, Stellen et cetera. Äh es gab immer mal wieder Fälle,
wo, ja, wo auch ähm ja, aber auch so ganz konkret, wo es auch so Anwerbungsversuche immer wieder gegeben hat und.
Teilweise gab's halt diese Anwerbungsversuche bei Leuten, weißt du, die irgendwie schon so im näheren Umfeld waren.
Die deshalb auch, sagen wir mal, angesprochen wurden, ja, die in irgendeiner Form als äh finde ich und beeinflussbar galten und wo dann irgendwelche ominösen Firmen,
gefragt haben, so ja, hier könntest du nicht mal ähm.
Hier mal so ein paar Aufgaben machen. Wir haben hier so ein paar äh Datenrecherchen und dann werden sozusagen wird man erstmal so ein bisschen getestet und wenn man dann irgendwie eins, zwei, drei Mal was irgendwie nett gemacht hat, dann kommen sie dann weiter, bist du dann halt irgendwann äh dich dabei wiederfindest äh irgendwelche,
zusammenzutragen, die in irgendeiner Form mit dem nuklearen Programm des Irans in Zusammenhang stehen.
Dann Gott sei Dank die betreffende Person auch kalte Füße bekommen hat und einfach zum Club gelatscht ist und gesagt hat, hier Hilfe, ja? Und,
Deswegen greife ich das jetzt gerade mal auf, weil das ist etwas, wo ich lese, der war siebzehn oder achtzehn, ja, ich meine, hier ist man schnell äh dabei, irgendwie Verräter zu schreien und Pipapo.
Hallo, ja, mit siebzehn und mit achtzehn und auch wahrscheinlich auch noch mit zwanzig. Äh und bei manchen Leuten und grad auch nochmal so bei Nerds,
häufig auch noch länger da herrscht einfach noch eine desorientierung und eine Unsicherheit im Leben, da ist man einfach sehr schnell benutzbar und,
Ähm da macht man auch schnell Dinge, die sich später als ein äh unglaublicher Fehler äh herausstellt, einfach aus Angst. War einfach äh unter Druck gerät, ja? Weiß der Geier, wie die,
damit ihm umgegangen sind. Ich meine, hier steht, er hat sich da selber angetragen, um sich irgendwie reinzuwaschen, ja, weil wahrscheinlich äh andererseitig äh Druck auch aus ihm ausgeübt wurde oder diesen Druck zumindest so empfunden hat, ja, in dieser ganzen Sache auch überfordert zu sein. Und das ist ja auch
sagen wir mal, alle, die wir so kennengelernt haben, sind ja auch nicht gerade wenig, die jetzt in irgendeiner Form in diesem WikiLeaks-Strom
mit sich gefangen sah, ja? Entweder nur so als Bekannte von oder irgendeiner Form aber irgendwas mitgemacht haben und sich einfach dieser Dimension so vielleicht vorher gar nicht
bewusst waren, das führt dann eben schnell zu einer Überforderung, weil man einfach diesen Bedrohungsszenarien, die damit verbunden sind, sich äh ausgeliefert sieht.
Nicht klarkriegt, ja, vielleicht eine Familie hat, auf einmal da entsprechend Angst bekommt, sich zurückzieht und in dem Moment, wo dann eben noch ein dritter Druck auf einen ausübt,
dann ins Schwimmen gerät. Und dann wird's halt natürlich auch besonders schwierig.
Ich wollte das nur mal kurz ansprechen. Mir fällt das gerade ein, einfach auch um so ein bisschen vielleicht die Jüngeren unter uns, die äh weißt du?
Sich vielleicht auch für für tolle Hechte halten und vielleicht auch welche sind, ja, die irgendwie was können und auch gerne äh sich mal beweisen, wenn ja in so Situationen geratet,
Irgendwie so ein bisschen fishi wird, so.
Nimmt euch zurück, ihr denkt da fünfmal drüber nach und wenn ihr irgendwie das Gefühl habt, ihr könnt diese Situation nicht mehr äh einschätzen.
Lauft zu jemandem wo einfach 'ne Vertrauenssituation auch hergestellt werden kann. Es sind jetzt nicht unbedingt grade Geheimdienste oder Medien, ja? Das sind definitiv Orte, die man meiden sollte.
Vielleicht eher etwas, was so im aktivistischen Bereich äh da bekannter ist, ja? Also wie gesagt, der Club hat sich äh,
häufig um solche Fälle gekümmert, weil das einfach da auch eine Rolle spielt. Und das ist einfach.
Sicherlich einige Personen, die da inzwischen einfach über jeden Zweifel erhaben, sind äh und man die man sich gerade in solchen Fällen äh sehr gut wenden kann.
Bevor man da einfach äh irgendwie in irgendwelche Dramen gerät oder einfach auch äh das Gefühl hat, man man man hat das alles nicht mehr unter Kontrolle und sich vielleicht auch in so einer äh Paranoia komplett verloren äh sieht,
ja äh ist es einfach Zeit da äh sich einfach mal zurückzunehmen und vielleicht auch einfach sein zu lassen, mal einfach mal was anderes machen, hilft auch,
Ja, das ist dieses diese ganze Datenwelt, die ist,
unglaublich aufregend und unglaublich spannend und ich weiß, dass ihr aus eigener Erfahrung dieses
Hacker sein und, und, und, und, auf Datennetzen unterwegs sein und diese ganzen äh zu erforschen, dass alles sehr, sehr spannend so. Nur wir merken auch, dieser ganze digitale Bereich,
hat ein ja, ein sehr unglückliche,
Wicklung mit allem. Ja, also da es sich eben hier um die Kommunikationsplattform der Zukunft.
Und eben ein Stück weit auch schon dagegen handelt, fliegen hier so viele Interessen durch die Luft, äh dass es eben,
ganz, dass man ganz gut daran tut, äh wohl zu sortieren, wo man sich aufgehoben sehen möchte.
Das mal dazu.
Und wenn ihr das nächste macht, lasst euren äh Server nicht vom Siebzehnjährigen alt ministrieren.
Ich will ja auch nicht generell allen Jungen jetzt
äh äh da das Misstrauen aussprechen. Das ist nicht das, was ich sagen will. Ich sage nur äh bestimmte Kräfte in dieser Welt äh erfordern eine gewisse Erfahrung, um mit ihnen auch umgehen zu können. Und wenn man auch nur das Gefühl hat, diese Erfahrung nicht zu haben, ist es vielleicht besser
sich da äh rauszuziehen und vielleicht zumindest den Rat anderer zu suchen.
Und zwar auch unabhängig vom Alter.
Genau. So, es war eigentlich durch, ne. Was hatten wir noch?
Geschichte, die ist etwas.
Die ist irgendwie komisch.
Ist etwas unübersichtlich, ja. Äh trotz alledem, ich wollt's mal ansprechen, weil's so,
Unabhängig davon, was da jetzt wirklich vorgefahren ist, stellt äh wird hier eine interessante Fragestellung aufgemacht. Also was ist passiert? Sascha Pallenberg, relativ bekannter äh Blogger
groß geworden mit dieser ganzen äh Network äh Sache, EPC, Network News, mittlerweile heißt das Mobile Geeks
ähm ist so ein Blogger, der auch gerne mal Tacheles äh äh redet, ist sicherlich jetzt so in seinem Wirken auch nicht unumstritten, aber wer ist das schon nicht
und ja der hat dann so eine Geschichte ausgegraben. Das angeblich äh hinter dem ähm.
Blogger Programm at Block Plus, eine deutsche Firma, beziehungsweise ein deutsches Firmengeflecht steht, was er dann sehr ausführlich ähm,
meint recherchiert zu haben und breitet diese Geschichte aus. Mittlerweile gibt's da einen offenen Schlag auf Abtausch,
Unternehmen versucht allerlei Gegendarstellungen äh zu machen. Es gibt mittlerweile einen zweiten, ich weiß nicht,
Das ist jetzt mein Stand. Es gab dann noch ein zweites Posting von äh Sascha Palmberg, wo er dann eben,
Viele dieser äh dort von diesem Unternehmen gemachte Behauptungen um wiederum zurückweisen, dass noch äh weiter auffächert und auch noch äh androht noch weitere Details da äh veröffentlichen zu können,
was ist im was sei passiert? Ich äh bleibe jetzt hier mal im Konjunktiv, weil ich jetzt nicht das so übernehmen will, weil es ist einfach äh.
Spielt sich irgendwie alles noch ab und es ist jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres äh äh zu bewerten, wer da jetzt irgendwie recht hat oder nicht äh recht hat, aber es stellt einfach eine interessante Fragestellung. Also der Vorwurf im Kern ist, AdBlock Plus,
blockt halt Werbung, aber manche ihn nicht. Und die, die nicht äh geblockt wird, äh das sind dann vor allem eben,
Firmen, die in irgendeiner Form mit diesem Unternehmen, was diesen AdBlock Plus betreibt im Zusammenhang steht, ist sowieso schon merkwürdig, dass eben so ein,
Blogger-Software da eben wirklich so eine größere deutsche Firma äh dahinter stehen hat, die ganz offensichtlich, dass es äh unbestritten ähm so ihre Finger im Werbegeschäft mit drin hat.
Das ist ja ungefähr so, als ob jetzt so ein Musikunternehmen irgendwie auf einmal anfängt, äh bitteren Plattformen zu betreiben,
Ja und äh das absurde äh an der Stelle ist, dass man eben
quasi hier wieder so eine ganz interessante Form von Gate Keeper äh aufgemacht hat. Also das eigentlich sich so eine Blogger äh Software
da äh äh reinsetzt in so dieser Einnahmestrom, der dann von manchen Leuten ausgeblendet wird und
Ja, man behauptet dann eben, mit so einer Community, von der Sascha Palmberg behauptet, dass die nicht sonderlich groß sein kann und im Wesentlichen, da wo es aktiv ist, aus den Mitarbeitern selber besteht
ähm da äh für für für ein sorgt, also bestimmte äh Websites eben sehr wohl äh die Werbung durchleiten lässt.
Nicht störende Werbung. Also der der.
Acceptable Ads heißt das.
Ja, also es waren so, das ist dann nicht irgendwelches blinkendes, trackendes Flash, wird dann suggeriert, wird suggeriert, das ist eine eine weniger störende Werbung, so die Suggestion und deshalb
äh gibt's also eine die man die bei Plus dann glaube ich auch per äh aktiviert ist, wo,
Sage ich mal jetzt dem dem unbedarften Internetnutzer, eigentlich dann suggeriert wird, ach haja, stimmt, die Verlage beschweren sich ja auch, dass äh dass ihnen die Einnahmen wegbleiben und machen irgendwie eine Kampagne, man soll die
Blocke ausmachen, dann tue ich ihnen doch den Gefallen, machen wir doch diesen Trade auf, dass ich sage,
Okay, wenn das nicht blinkt oder so, wenn das eben acceptable ist, dann soll AdBord Plus das nicht filtern.
Genau, also dadurch etabliert sich dann halt äh dann doch eben wieder ein Filter und das ist äh etwas, was man an der Stelle vielleicht einfach mal bedenken soll, ne.
Und es scheint also der Vorwurf ist ja jetzt wohl, dass das AdBlockplus diesen exaptable,
Teil, der wird nicht durch eine Community festgelegt, sondern der wird durch Preise festgelegt. Die, die entsprechenden Seiten oder werbeschaltenden ähm bezahlen. Das heißt, AdBlock Plus.
Beziehungsweise es gibt dann halt auch so Beteiligungsverpflichtungen und äh dass einfach Personen, die hinter Elbblock Plus stehen, eben auch entsprechend bei den Unternehmen beteiligt sind, die ihnen da drin sind. Da steckt irgendwie ja Juden ähm jetzt habe ich,
Jetzt habe ich den Namen nicht richtig, deswegen sage ich Ihnen gerade mal nicht, weil sonst sage ich was Falsches. Äh könnt ihr auch auf jeden Fall alles nachlesen. Wir verlinken mal die beiden äh Einträge von äh Sascha Palmberg, da sind dann auch die Repliken drin.
Beiden habe ich auch verlinkt, ja.
Sind's jetzt zwei schon? Ja okay, also wie gesagt, es geht da hin und her. Wir bewerten jetzt mal äh nicht, was davon jetzt wirklich stimmt oder nicht. Interessant ist der Vorwurf auf jeden Fall und man muss sich eben fragen, äh ob man,
ja, ob man da nicht an irgendeiner Stelle neu geht, Keeper Funktionen schafft, um das Ganze einem etwas anderes vorgaukelt, als es tatsächlich ist.
Der erste Artikel von äh von Sascha Peinbeck ist ja sowas von ausführlich und so viel. Ich bin ja sehr gespannt, also der der zweite äh dann auch. Ich.
Also der muss sich seiner Sache schon echt sicher sein, weil sonst.
Ahnung, die er sich dafür einhandelt und das Gerichtsverfahren, wenn da irgendwie ein Komma falsch gesetzt ist in dem Artikel, äh das wird äh ihnen wäre sehr teuer
und äh die erste Reaktion äh von AdBlock Plus war ja sogar ja, was der Palmberg da ähm,
schreibt äh entspricht erstmal so den Fakten, aber er interpretiert die Fakten halt falsch.
Ja, also die diese Replik ist schon so ein bisschen absurd. Also, was sie so als äh sie haben da wirklich so einen äh Stil mit Fakt Doppelpunkt, das ist Irrsinn.
Ja, also äh.
Also da musste ich schon sagen, äh hallo, geht's noch? Also wenn das jetzt irgendwie eine Faktenaufzählung sein soll, dann seid ihr schon äh
doch weit ab von der Spur, ne. Was aber noch dahinter steckt, ich will jetzt nicht zu weit äh alles wiederholen, was ich da gelesen habe, aber es gibt ja noch weitere Unternehmen, die dann eben sozusagen auch in diesem excited Adds mit drin sind, die dann eben auch teilweise äh
Links verstärken, also sozusagen diese Methode ähm,
Link auf Amazon und äh auf ähnliche Dienste, also vor allem natürlich Amazon, die doch Beteiligung teilweise ausspucken, besonders, wenn man ein hohes Linkaufkommen hat,
ähm werden dann sozusagen automatisch ersetzt, ja. Sprich man surft mit AdBlock Plus kommt auf Seiten, wo,
Äh Amazon links drauf sind und die werden dann sozusagen magisch auf einmal zu Affiliate-Links, ja. Das heißt, man spült da an der Stelle äh anderen Leuten, die eigentlich mit.
Sozusagen überhaupt gar keine Leistung erbracht haben, äh Geld in die Kasse,
Was im Übrigen auch gegen die Amazon ähm Prinzipien verstößt, soweit ich da informiert bin, also,
ziemlicher Wahrscheinlichkeit ist es das, weil das ist nicht das, was sie intendiert haben, ne. Äh und Palmberg unter äh meint ja auch noch, es sei,
sogar also es gibt ja so ein beschreibenden Text, wenn man sich das durchliest, ist schon so, ja, wir machen das ja eigentlich nicht, aber wenn es denn unbedingt willst, dann kannst du's auch einschalten, dass eben sogar existierende Affiliate-Links überschrieben werden, also das ist schon,
ziemlich haarsträubend so, ne? Ich meine, gut, in dem Business, da wird ohnehin mit harten Bandagen.
Es macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob hier eben so ein weiterer Player mal ein bisschen demaskiert worden ist.
Was äh dann noch kurz so anzumerken ist ähm es gibt AdBlock und AdBlockplus.
Genau und das eine ist nicht das andere.
Empfehlung äh geht er also zum AdBlock und man ne auch auch hier.
Jetzt werbsfrei gesprochen, wenn du erstmal an dem Punkt bist, ein Plug-in zu haben, das Werbung auf, sagen wir mal, einen nennenswerten Prozentsatz, der der,
internationalen Webbrowser sperrt, dann ist es natürlich, ist natürlich genau dieses Geschäftsmodell,
kleine Fehler in deinem AdBlocker oder auch absichtlich oder diese zu haben, ist natürlich dann auch sehr, sehr naheliegend. Das heißt, äh mit anderen Worten, es sollte,
ein vernünftiger Ansatz zum Werbesperren sollte also äh,
auf einen auf die eine oder andere Weise transparent und äh quäl offen sein, um genau diesen Anreiz einfach zu vermeiden für Menschen, die dann diese.
Die dann diese Sachen unter diese Listen unterhalten, diese letztendlich Sperrlisten und was 'ne AdBlocker eigentlich macht, also wie der in den Aufbau der Webseite eingreift, das ist schon sehr tiefgehend, ja? Also ähm,
der rein technisch ist so dieses ich nehme diesen Teil raus, ich stelle ihn dem Nutzer nicht da,
obwohl es jetzt im Prinzip im Sinne des Betreibers der Seite ist, dass dieser Teil dort dieser Inhalt an der Stelle steht. Ähm das ist technisch schon relativ äh krasser Eingriff, der natürlich auch ähm,
ja
vergleichbar ist mit äh also technisch nichts anderes ist als eine als eine Zensur, ja? Also nur vom Technischen, also ich sage nicht, ein Ad Locker ist Zensur, ich nutze selber AdBlocker, selbstverständlich. Ähm man muss sich nur äh schon darüber im Klaren sein, aus,
wie viel Vertrauen auch damit einhergeht, wenn man so einen AdBlocker nutzt.
Und wenn wir davon von Manipulation von äh von äh Affiliate Links reden oder so, dann äh reden wir da halt schon über was sehr ernstes. Also auch hier wieder, ne, freie.
Ja so und
es gibt ja nun sehr viele, die sich eben über Werbung äh refinanzieren. So, dazu kann man dann stehen, wie man äh will, aber ich halte das jetzt auch nicht für grundsätzlich illegitim so, das äh kann man natürlich äh
machen, ja? Also Disclaimer, auch hier äh in der Mieterebene verwende ich halt äh Affiliate-Links, weil ich das als sehr,
Ähm wie soll ich sagen, akzeptable Form finde
ähm akzeptable Formen der der Sekundär Gewinnerzielung, weil man eben jetzt keinem irgendwie unbedingt Werbung ins Gesicht drückt. Ist natürlich generell ein Problem, ne, weil wenn du solchen bevorzugen hast
Vorzugen hast, dann stehst du natürlich immer schnell auch äh in dem Verdacht,
Aussagen so zu leiten, um solche Links dann auch erstmal erzeugen zu können und so.
Das ist ein schwieriges äh Feld, das ein Minenfeld, dessen bin ich mir auch sehr wohl bewusst.
Sind wir glaube ich dann durch.
Fällt mir noch was ein. Grade hier. Ja, die App für die, die Werbethematik im Internet werden wir nicht abschließend lösen. Äh.
Nein, werden wir nicht, aber wir äh bleiben auf jeden Fall hier am äh Geschehen dran. Wir sagen vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Sagen wir, oder? Komm, sag mal.
Ja, danke.
Bis bald.